President Trump said in the radio
interview this morning the tariffs on
China may cause a little pain but he
insists there's no trade war the
president asked the US Trade
Representative last night to consider
tariffs on another 100 billion dollars
of Chinese made goods mr. Trump accused
China of quote unfair retaliation for
his previous round of proposed tariffs
China's government is not impressed and
vows to keep fighting Ben Tracy is in
Beijing then good morning good morning
the White House may be hoping it can
somehow scare China into making major
trade concessions but so far the Chinese
government is not flinching China's
foreign ministry released a statement
that says we do not want to fight but we
are not afraid to fight a trade war it
went on to say that China will not
hesitate to pay any price and will fight
back firmly now China has already
threatened fifty billion dollars of
tariffs on US goods including
high-profile US exports such as soybeans
pork and aircraft now that was in
response to president Trump's proposed
50 billion in tariffs on Chinese goods
earlier this week but China has also
made it clear it will only go through
with its threats if the White House
actually imposes its tariffs now right
now all of these tariffs are just
proposals and the Chinese say they want
to negotiate but if neither President
Trump or President Xi Jinping of China
backed down
that means we could be looking at a
full-blown trade war between the two
biggest economies in the world John all
right then trace it for us thanks so
much better